there's something to be said about
um
the the I I never assume that anyone is
going to actually know who the hell I am
and and quite frankly if they do they
probably don't even remember my name I'm
just someone else's uh like attachment
like oh you're so and so son right okay
so that's that's fine that's a whole
other can of worms but like the idea
that someone could say
I saw you in something I don't remember
exactly what it is but I remember it
being good that is like on on like the
meter of like you never want someone to
go
how do I know you what's that how do I
work tell me tell me what you've been in
yeah and you go well I was in this thing
no not that well I was in this other
thing no definitely not that the the oh
I saw that no you're not in that area
the idea that someone could say I
remember you from something I liked and
you made an impression that to me struck
me as like that's a good pla that's a
good place to aim for right where they
go I believed you
truly like that I believed you enough to
go oh yeah he was great in that one
thing that I saw and I remember liking
but I don't remember what the name is
that to me struck me as like that's the
sweet spot that that you want to be in
and I've been on the other end of it too
where I've been talking to people that I
idolize
and I realized
uh cut it off I mean not not a not a
professional interview setting but I run
into them
and I start to realize I step outside
myself and say you're talking too much
you know it doesn't get better then oh
my God you're one of my favorite I I was
in New York uh recently when I was in a
restaurant and I'm leaving and I see oh
my God Albert Al Pacino is in the corner
sitting at a table I mean there's that's
Al Pacino well he was in The Godfather
I'm just assuming that you don't
remember what you said no idea he was in
The Godfather he was also in a Thing
Called Scent of a Woman which a lot of
people that's what I know him yeah there
you go but I saw him and um he like
suddenly he sees me he's motioning me
motioning me over and I'm like wow so I
go over and he's like it's good to see
him I'm like wow wow Mr Pacino this is
fantastic and then I'm talking and all I
said like look you're this one of my
favorite and I've met him before
casually but I just want you're just I
just have to say you're one of my
favorite actors of all time appreciate
it appreciate it very much and then I
kept talking and then I had just seen
Serpico like two nights before and
there's a scene in Serpico or he's
chasing someone through like uh he's
chasing someone uh who's trying to get
away from a robbery and uh he tackles
him near a Stairway and they both fall
all the way down the stairs and it's
clearly it's it's it's Al Pacino falling
all the way down the stairs and I went
and then serpica so serpicone he's going
oh I'll tell you and I went
going he's looking at me and kind of
smiling and nodding he fell down these
stairs in 1974. and also it is not a
critical part of the movie
it's not it's not important to the movie
at all it's just what I remember and I'm
like you you fell down those stairs and
he went well yeah and I went then I
realized get out get out pass you've
you've ruined everything and I went well
I've got to go and I kind of ran away
and then
um weeks later I meet this person who
was sitting at the table with him who's
a film producer who said we saw you in
New York and I went oh yeah yeah yeah
and then you just you were talking in
like mid-sentence you said gotta go and
ran away and Al Pacino was like what do
you run away for I wanted to tell you I
was enjoying talking to him you know I
was like oh no
and uh so I'm I think I'm the first
person maybe in 50 years who Al Pacino
was talking to and I'm like yeah I'm out
and ran away got in your head I got in
my head so I got in my head one way I
talked too much you fell down those
stairs yeah what stairs you [ __ ] up
what you talking about and then I I got
my head the other way and ran away he's
self-cock block rudely it's self-cock if
there is that but getting in in your
head that I I've been there I've
definitely like gotten to the point
where it's like shut the hell up shut
the hell up you're talking too much
you're talking too much stop which is
why like I always I I really do truly
feel this way like I I I try very very
hard to express how much I admire
somebody for their work and I like to
separate them and their work so they
don't like just like it's a weird
distinction but it's one that I'm sort
of obsessed with and I and and the
highest compliment really can be like I
believe you every time I see you oh
that's a good one and that to me is I
just every time I see you know a certain
actor you know I I will make it a point
to say like look I just want to say I
believe you every time I see you on the
screen and that I think is the most
succinct way that I can express my
admiration because otherwise I will go
on for 20 minutes about you know
so and so falling down the stairs and
that not being a stunt double and then
halfway through going maybe he hit his
head and he doesn't remember that he
went down the stairs and then oh my God
and you keep talking yeah do you ever
say that to actors who you don't really
mean it about what you mean I believe
hey Vin Diesel I believe you every time
no that's when you go but man that music
when you did that scene where you and
and that music kicks in yeah that's me
saying man that music was really telling
me how I'm supposed to feel right now
and I'm not picking on Vin Diesel I just
saw him recently in Hamlet and I didn't
buy it
early in the First Act he gets in a car
and uh
I heard he fell down the stairs
the stairs were damaged when he fell
down the stairs that's uh that's on me